We Begin this hour with another deadly
mass shooting in America this time at a
block party in Baltimore two people were
killed and 28 more injured at least 14
of those hurt were minors police are
still looking for suspects they think
there was one there was more than one
shooter Baltimore's mayor Brandon Scott
vowed investigators would not stop until
the perpetrators are caught Mayor Scott
joins us now from the city of Baltimore
Mr Mayor good morning good to see you
and I'm curious if you can give us the
latest on the investigation
well the latest is that we are still
looking for those who commonly decided
to disrupt a a block party in Brooklyn
and murder two people in ninja 20 others
and cause trauma to so many others that
live in that community and that were at
the event and that we still we are not
going to stop until we find them and
hold them accountable but we're not just
going to stop at them we're going to try
to find out who sold who traffic that
gun into Baltimore and hope everybody on
the Chain responsible because that's
what we need to start doing in this
country
Mr Mayor you mentioned this was that a
block party over a holiday weekend and
some of the victims were as young as 13.
do we know if this was a targeted
shooting
we don't know we don't know that we'll
come out in the investigation but I
think what's important for folks
especially those like you in the
National media to know that now what
you're seeing across this country this
is not the 1990s you are seeing people
shoot and hurt and kill each other over
just basic conflict we don't know that
that's what happened but that's what the
leading cause of shootings in our city
is over and over again it's basic
conflict and we know that we can resolve
conflict in a better way but we have to
have the conversation again about
another mass shooting in this country
and we're talking about still in action
at the national level we here in
Maryland have the best Federal
Congressional Delegation but we need all
of Congress to get on board and enact
real gun law changes to prevent folks
who shouldn't have them to being able to
have that access it should not be easier
for a young person to go online and
order a ghost gun than it is for me to
get some Claritin D from my local
neighborhood pharmacy
well let's talk about what the city of
Baltimore is dealing with you know
amongst the highest murder rates in the
U.S 300 homicides in Baltimore every
year since 2015. an understaffed Police
Department do you have a police
department that has the ability to
tackle this
well listen this I think this is another
misconception in this country anybody
that tells you that reducing homicides
and shootings in a community is solely
on the on the backs of police officers
doesn't know what they're talking about
we have to understand that they have a
job and we're going to empower them to
do that even with this mass shooting and
this incident that we have Baltimore is
seeing a 20 reduction in a homicides
year over year and even in reduction in
non-fatal shootings even with this
shooting we have recovered over 1300
weapons but it's not just about the
great women and men of BPD who are doing
that work through reform through a
consent decree but it's also about the
mayor's office neighborhood safety
engagement our safe trees violence
intervention workers folks like
Community organizations like we are us
people are doing the behavioral health
work that we should have our
hospital-based violence responders their
trauma work those who work at Recreation
and Parks everybody that works for city
government every Community partner every
organization every religious
organization station plays apart and
reducing violence this country has full
far too long put that all on the backs
of police officers we can no longer do
that we have to allow them to do their
job and focus their job which it should
be on people that are shooting and
killing people around trafficking
weapons of removing mental health
behavioral health off of their plate and
allowing people who are trained to do
that we're going to continue to do that
work in this entirety here in Baltimore
we can continue to recruit police
officers but we're also going to
continue demand like all my brother and
sister Mayors around the country for
Congress to get serious and do something
like they said they would way back in
1999 when Columbine happened and nothing
has changed since
Mr Mayor you and I spoke back in early
2021 and at the time it was just after
you took office and I said why did you
want to be mayor and you told me in part
I'm a Baltimore boy when you grow up in
a neighborhood that the world descends
on for a horse race named Preakness and
every other day of the year you're not
seen as human by your own city
government it changes you and you
recalled how you hit yourself had seen a
shooting before the age of 10. you said
quote you make a decision on do you want
to accept that or do you want to do
something to change it and I'm just
wondering in the year and a half or so
since
two and a half years since do you think
you've done enough to change your city
and to make sure that other kids under
the age of 10 aren't seeing this kind of
violence
well every every day I want to do more
right yes we've made a lot of changes in
the way that we invest record numbers of
investments into our schools open up
five recreation centers five more that
are going to be built including one
three minutes walking distance from
where this shooting happened but we have
more work to do in every day I want
myself to be better because I know that
this is something that has been
happening in my city longer than I've
been breathing air longer than my
parents have been even in Baltimore city
right but we have to do that work each
and every day it starts with me but
everyone has to do that thing of looking
in the mirror and saying what can they
do as well so I'm going to always
challenge myself to do more how can I be
better for all of my residents in
Baltimore starting with our young people
and our older adults and making sure
that we're doing everything in our power
there we will not stop I will not stop
as long as there's breath in my body I'm
going to do what I can do to make
Baltimore better that's why we make
those historical levels of investment
that's why we've changed the way we deal
with Public Safety thinking about the
totality of those incidents as well
Mr Mayor thank you so much for joining
us and talking about we'll talk about it
again soon because this isn't something
that ends with just the shooting as you
said it's a long problem